what is my perfect crime i break into
tiffany's at midnight
do i go for the vault no i go for the
chandelier it's priceless
as i'm taking it down a woman catches me
she tells me to stop
it's her father's business she's tiffany
i say no
we make love all night in the morning
the cops come and i escape in one of
their uniforms
i tell her to meet me in mexico but i go
to canada i don't trust her
besides i like the cold 30 years later i
get a postcard
i have a son and he's the chief of
police this is where the story gets
interesting
i tell tiffany to meet me in paris by
the trocadero
she's been waiting for me all these
years she's never taken another lover
i don't care i don't show up i go to
berlin that's where i stash the
chandelier
are you okay son did you get any sleep
ah not really i stayed up most of the
night
but that's not important let me tell you
about
rent-a-swag no need tom i'm in i like
doing business with serious people
and when you removed yourself from the
company of that [__]
you showed me you're a serious person
you have your startup money
wow i appreciate it
tommy t you just missed the craziest of
crazies
clubs girls dancing naked mom
argument police fleeing the seed hiding
in a dumpster coming here
crashing on your couch for a week cause
technically i'm homeless
hey mustache i'ma hit the couch you know
i'll be
hey you guys i thought of a funny
response to terry's text from earlier
would you mind taking a look before i
hit send charles you've trained for this
moment okay
we trust you just send it come here good
job
all right i'm gonna do it mm-hmm didn't
do it
okay everybody just calm down
count of three we're all gonna put down
our guns
i have crossbows we'll put down our
weaponry on the count of three okay
you ready i'm ready one
two three
and he revealed himself to be a double
agent at which point dwight felt
comfortable revealing that he also was a
double agent and then
michael announced everybody that get
this
he was a double agent oh and it is six
o'clock
really it wasn't me
i'm not going down for this yeah i want
to go home
get the keys out of my purse start the
car
hmm
if i thought you were serious i'd be
offended bird but i know that we're
buddies and i know you wouldn't do that
to me but no
this is a birthmark perd okay this is
the little scar i got when i was nine
and i fell off my bike so no
i'm not perfect i can't look away it's
um
it's amazing okay we're all right no
here's the best part okay
uh that's all the time we have here on
you heard
i'm heard happily channel four more like
turd crapley
[Applause]
i call the game real ray or fake ray and
joining us is a very special contestant
captain ray holt himself
all right here's how the game works i
will say a phrase you tell me if i made
it up
or if it's something that captain holt
actually said in real life to an actual
human being
i understand the logic of this game
great phrase number one
the futility of lighting candles only to
blow them out immediately
is just one reason i find children's
birthday parties
impractical that's all fake i say
fake tooth i don't remember saying it so
it must be fake it was real
carries kids at their birthday party oh
i remember now
okay do another one dude all right
phrase number two any smile
that lasts longer than a second and a
half is a con man's ruse that's fake
i think that's okay i said it and i
meant it sitting in my office with a
plate of grilled bigots
call my man's wife just to see what was
shaking yo mike our town is dope and
pretty so check out how we live
in the electric city they call it
scranton what
the electric city script what the
electric city
lazy scranton the electric city they
call it that cause of the electricity
the city's laid out from east to west
and our public parks and libraries are
truly the best
call poison control if you're bit by a
spider but
check that it's covered by your health
care provider plenty of space in the
parking lot but the little cars go win
the compact spot
spot spot spot snack attack time don't
lose your head
we like who genus for the tasty bread
the college grant what the electric city
clinton what the electric
city script what the electric city
scrape want the electric city sprint
[Music]
the internet's not working ben we need
your help
guys i've told you how to do it you just
unplug the router and then you plug it
back in again
i guess i'll do it
still not working well give it a minute
good
okay it's working
ah kevin let me just get my coat hello
peralta
gina oh sweet lords of dance thank you
we're back on a first name basis kevin i
am unable and unwilling to discuss
personal matters with you
i'm aware of that yes in any case thank
you for your help i brought you both
gifts
original raymond holtz i will treasure
this painting of iraq for all times
uh rock 59 and 367.
those are good rocks 367 paintings of
one rock
this guy parties in the criminal justice
system
the people are represented by two
separate but equally important groups
the police who investigate the crimes
and the district attorneys who prosecute
the offenders
these are their stories
i'm just a cleaning lady ah
dead body he wrapped his belt around his
own neck
it looks like a classic case of
autoerotic asphyxiation
yeah it looks like everybody's
tightening their belts in this economy
the last time you saw the victim was he
happy last time i saw this john
he was he wasn't a victim if you know
what i'm talking about
thank you no that's just i'm just
getting into the first act
yeah i love cop gangs alice hates you
annie has herpes if what's your problem
my problem is you
smell us ben told you to finish the
website and if you don't do it i swear
to god i'm gonna murder you
in your sleep i know where you live 14th
street right i'm gonna get a melon
baller and scoop your eyes out and eat
them
and your congressman uncle's gonna have
to buy you a dog to drag your eyeless
face around do you understand me yes
do it okay
oh forgot about this one we never
watched captain corelli's mandolin
what the hell did you just say captain
corelli's mandolin
say that to my face captain girl's panel
there was a movie about a mandolin and
you kept it from me for two months
i didn't think it was any good it's just
some period piece set in grease oh my
god based on some dumb book
terribly sorry it has been a very
trying time yeah next thing you're gonna
say you wish we would watch leaving las
vegas a dark ponderous reflection on
alcoholism that encaged his oscar
what i told you the guy's got range
hey it's 12 20 where the hell's dwight
um no idea never miss a day my ass
over here i'm here
over here it's okay
hi ron hi ron
ladies ladies
[Applause]
um
you